[Music]
[Applause]
taylor swift holds the record for most
american music awards
and it makes sense she's been a huge
supporter of the fan voted show
for years first showing up in 2007.
she made her ama performance debut in
2008 though
singing white horse
she also won her first ama that night
her favorite female country artist
i was really nervous about the award i
was i've been nervous about everything
anything that has to do with award shows
i'm nervous about but
it's over now and i can't believe that i
actually won that award it's amazing
taylor returned to the ama stage in 2010
with another emotional performance
this time back to december
[Music]
it was after that that taylor's
transition to pop began
in 2012 she hit the stage with i knew
you were trouble for the first time live
[Music]
and we got that unforgettable costume
[Music]
change
i'm just so thankful to the fans for
making it such a success
and for liking it you know that's a good
thing
the very next year 2013 taylor clenched
her
sixth consecutive ama for favorite
female country artist
and she won her third artist of the year
award it's pretty great tonight the fans
keep raising the bar on
they keep just getting better and better
and doing more amazing things so for me
like it makes me want to raise the bar
on the music i'm making and
make an even better next record in 2014
the awards kept coming
taylor was honored with the first ever
dick clark award for excellence
she also delivered an epic performance
of blank space
[Music]
during her speech she defended the value
of albums in a streaming era
what you did by by going out and
investing in music and albums is
you're saying that you believe in the
same thing that i believe in that
music is valuable and that music should
be consumed in albums and albums
should be consumed as art and
appreciated and i love you so much
taylor didn't return to the amas until
2018.
she opened the show with a highly
anticipated and fiery performance of i
did something bad
[Music]
it was also at this show where she
encouraged fans to vote
this award and every single award given
out tonight
were voted on by the people and you know
what else is voted on by the people
is the midterm elections on november 6th
get out and vote i love you guys
in 2019 taylor made history surpassing
michael jackson as the artist with the
most
american music awards she was also the
recipient of the artist of the decade
award
and performed a medley of some of her
biggest hits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sick
[Music]